now this time we're doing things a
little differently and I mean
differently
time to get changed now when people know
I'm coming they all tend to be on their
best Bloody Behavior so I'm going
undercover to catch all of them off
guard
in order to blend in I've invited four
local musicians to camouflage me going
undercover sounds amazing ready for
lunch let's go
over here
excuse me hello guys how are you oh yeah
let me get your server
we become busy that street is out there
how can a restaurant find some misery
with some difference there businesses on
either side of this are packed
yeah
I have the fleur-de-li chicken please
we're ordering classic New Orleans
dishes eggs Jonathan crawfish that any
restaurant in The Big Easy should be
able to perfect well
Band-Aid I just cut the [__] out myself
totally redfish
she's in the Crawfish
is that a right fish
it's funny how all the three witches are
standing in the bar
you got it girl yeah baby
where's
Frozen but it's not bad it's probably
good though I think it's time to change
how they ended I think it was bleeding
through it
it's been a minute huh
what happened put it wrong please
excuse me
too busy man
ah screwed it up thank you like the
redfish
thank you
toast looks pretty burnt when a
restaurant
toast rights you know we're [__]
how do you like your eggs man
I'm not sure yet
in the center yeah
not good not good
you're welcome
so I've got a rotten fries
I'm gonna swap the chicken
the chicken smells funny I don't know
what they've done to it
please don't eat anymore what I
discovered in the kitchen is pretty
gross and what I'm about to show you in
a couple of minutes is knocking I've
seen enough excuse me no problem
[Music]
I've never seen anything that bad ever
and the atmosphere was terrible
it smells in there
it's like the restrooms giving up and no
one gives a [__]
[Music]
right time to take the family
from Italian who's hungry
let's go this disguise pays homage to
one of my favorite comedies
the National Lampoon Vacation movies
[Music]
great hopefully our meal is less
disastrous than some of the vacations oh
man
here we go
forward please sure right this way when
you walk into Bella Diana's your first
instinct is to walk right back out so
then one table 23 please I'm sorry 43.
how depressing is this
the tacky decor and the uninviting staff
makes you feel immediately unwelcome you
need a few minutes or are you ready no
no what nope we're ready nope we need a
few minutes okay can we order a
magalamari we've ordered a variety of
classic Italian dishes and spaghetti
meatballs very good I'll be right back
thank you if you can't do these staples
properly if I calamari fake clamps
chopped first then a family [__]
salad you have no business being in the
restaurant business I have the two
appetizers yeah go ahead go for it so
this is that's the big clams take on and
say a prayer let's see what I've got in
mind then
times are really salty I know it tastes
like I'm eating just bread crumbs
so you're playing with no clam did you
get a plan
calamari is rubbery it's not even crispy
they tastes old if you like I can give
you a little on each of your dish if you
want these clams are horrendous okay
there is not a clam okay here I'd be
more than happy to take them off the
track yeah you got it
whatever he wants
hello yes clam sucked up
my sister sucks it's Gotta stop
it's [__] [__]
yeah I know yeah okay dip it up you can
cook yourself yeah cook yourself yeah I
know because I'm the one saying this I'm
making it up yeah I know
put my salad
this salad is appalling oh
it's dead don't eat the dressing it
smelled like the backseat of my car
spaghetti meatballs eggplant parm
may we not end up
in the ER thank you
that's horrendous oh my God that looks
like the inside of my grandfather's
Underpants that looks like a placenta I
would not feed this to my dog I will do
it this is horrendous dear tremendous
meaning you want me to take it away you
didn't like it there it was horrible
okay great honey take it away Daniel
please you know what if you like the
whole bit is on me enjoy okay okay well
you don't have to be nasty dear you
don't like anything you don't have to be
nasty my nasty at all dear
thank you wow
it seems like that
see how he's always angry
it's like they're scared of him hey said
the veal soft the eggplant soft this
sucked everything sucks so it's [__]
[__] I'm done so [__] done it's
[__] [__] see in a minute nothing
enough oh please
where's Daniel you know what why don't
you buy them coffee and dessert too so
they complain about that too tell them
it's on me everything because our food
sucks because it's [__] [__] holy
[__]
oh man that was absolutely shocking
man when people know I'm coming they all
tend to be on their best Bloody Behavior
so I'm going undercover to catch all of
them off guard
[Music]
Right Time for night out the town good
evening guys today I'm getting together
with some friends from the neighborhood
let's go
to blend in with the locals so I can get
the inside scoop on The Brownstone
Bistro
yo yo yo good to see you guys
um there is no presence in the dining
room no host no manager no greetings
we're ordering classic Caravan dishes
that any authentic Jamaican restaurant
should be able to do yeah can we get the
lobster mac and cheese please okay so
lobster mac and cheese The Jerk wings
for the whole team and the jerk Wing
salsa I'll do the grilled ribeye the oxy
okay great okay coming up okay
no they don't look in love with their
job
dig in
oh my wings cold in the middle
when a restaurant can't get a wing right
it doesn't hold up much for the entrees
does it and where in the [__] is the
lobster the cheese looks like it's been
sprayed out I can it does not look fresh
at all
um oxtails thank you and I'm gonna watch
y'all I'll eat yeah where's yours just a
moment you were by coming up to
[Laughter]
spare time
man
I've had enough it's time to get out
this disguise and get to work
oh Lord
that was pretty bad oh my goodness
wow